no habrá globos ni público para correr
el nombre de joe biden sino docenas de
computadoras y técnicos con mascarillas
repartidos por todo este centro de
convenciones de milwaukee en la era del
cob y 19 la convención nacional
demócrata será virtual una primicia en
la historia de esta celebración política
lo que ven detrás de mí es el centro
neurálgico técnico para que millones de
estadounidenses en todo el país y aquí
en milwaukee puedan asistir a la
convención durante cuatro días los
grandes nombres del partido se turnarán
para hablar por videoconferencia
mientras que los delegados encargados de
nominar oficialmente al candidato
presidencial votarán a distancia desde
bernie sanders a bill clinton barack
obama
kamala harris hillary clinton y michelle
obama todos deberían subrayar la
importancia de unificar el país un valor
esencial ya que quieren mostrar la
imagen de un partido unido para hacer
frente a donald jones para los
republicanos esta convención es una
demostración de ego frente a donald
trump
pero para los demócratas si yo weyden
fue muy claro sobre esto no se trata de
ego se trata de nuestra visión como
nación cómo vamos a construir unos
estados unidos
d se está hablando de bailan por su
parte para el tradicional discurso de
aceptación de la nominación el candidato
demócrata joe biden hablará desde la
ciudad de wilmington donde vive un
discurso muy esperado que cerrará la
convención el 20 de agosto